hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Octodad dadliest
catch now a lot of people were very very
adamant that I continue playing this
game and personally this game is
absolutely amazing so I'm gonna be doing
a full let's play of it and let's get
right into it
I'm getting kind of good at the controls
using a gamepad
it's amazing what two joysticks and good
thumbs can do take that for what it will
Oh God
excuse me hello how are you doing today
sir oh wait is that blood on the floor I
don't know what I'm concerned more about
the Segway or the fact that there is a
lot of blood on that floor over there oh
well whatever it's okay I'm fine excuse
me sir I'm just being an average
everyday squid over here
that's incredible oh can I use these oh
my god please tell me I can use the
Stunna shades oh come on mark it on the
face come on oh my god yes oh I am
totally awesome okay so find the frozen
pizza that would be it
frozen pizza brand pizza give me why I
just do my little dance again or the
pizza I call this one the pizza dance
[Music]
okay let's get the pizza before anyone
gets weirded out by whatever the hell
I'm doing come on come on come on
no do these glasses look like I work
here
anyone that's a little disturbing I'm
trying to grab the pizza lady can you
please move on I'm just a normal average
everyday squid I mean human trying to
get some gosh dang pizza how about this
one that's out of order over here pop
maybe because everything's automated I
can't over here wait but we're sure at
least one freezer door is working uh-huh
okay tonight okay can I have that maybe
because oh I know what I need to do I
need to farm right no no oh oh I know
what I need to do I need to get in there
I'm a squid what's the problem ain't
nothing wrong with me oh good golly no
way no way there is no way how in the
world oh okay
so this is how it's gonna be we're gonna
drive me crazy
right off the bat okay I just got to get
my leg up in there
gotta get Oh God okay yeah other leg up
with the other leg up up with off with
see other leg
no no grab that okay just come on grab
onto something
come on octopi confusingly difficult
okay oh it probably would have been
easier just to move this stuff out of
the way
and then go down the lower one I've
never done anything easily I always take
the hard route when it comes to these
things oh my god where did I go oh no
nobody's yeah as a pizza baby
I got the pizza baby yeah all right so
that's good do I need it Oh get Tommy Oh
what shirtless chefs young horses two
and a half Kevin's sparse and parker who
the heck is chrysalis to know oh ok
never mind you know what it was fine the
way it was
I'll deal with that later time to get
the cereal the slide ever so I did and
was that a unicorn I saw didn't Mike I
think my daughter needed this unicorn
didn't eat did she not okay you get one
of those and then I'm gonna kill you did
you already make one of those I don't
want to hear any more other jokes ever
okay so I have this but I'm guessing I
don't need this right now
cuz I know my daughter needs for the big
game maybe for a big party only Gerson's
has a soda city big enough to handle all
your biggest events way up there how in
the world you explain me to go up there
oh wait maybe that's a maybe that's a
super blammo this is soda I want
slurp slurp shove it right in my octopus
face stash thing okay never mind
okay moving on didn't see you thing
there
okay we're just got all this stairs over
here delightful
just cut up just dance a little bit and
there we go
hope you don't mind as i straddle these
stairs like this ah yeah
oh you like that you like that you
whatever you are cream soda
okay okay all right I'm gonna abandon
those stairs and go up these much nicer
stairs okay but I'm gonna go up no one's
looking to me okay just decide to
straddle again I know you spent a lot of
time as a stripper working your way
through college mr. octopus but this is
not the time you're known for your very
flexible acts very impressive yes come
on okay just can you all right you know
what fine just okay just wait for it
it's gonna come oh you aggravating son
of a monkey nutter okay you know what
it's fine it's fine it's fine I'm
getting the hang of it kind of maybe a
little bit
oh yeah just want to dance some more oh
I wanted to be all there I saw I wanted
a soda
continue okay all right you know what
I'm beginning to think that you're just
with me now
okay raise a leg move it over slowly I
could get get it on yeah there no no no
no no no over there no can I have the
soda raised leg put leg down raise other
leg gently camera if you would stop
freaking out for two seconds okay but
leg down is it caught raise leg move
over but no raise leg raise arm raised
arm raise leg place leg no don't flip
flop the camera I okay place leg raise
other leg place leg play place place it
place it okay raised arm okay just wait
patiently wait patiently hi everybody
it's me totally normal totally normal
no one pay mind god that was the hardest
thing I've ever done and I've given
birth to like tension oh I have not
that's not what I've knows knows not me
okay anyway can you get down from there
now please Oh
oh and now to find the perfect Apple the
most splendiferous Apple in the world Oh
with someone on a banana eating spree
over here was my good friend
donkey dad over here okay be normal
yes what I like I'm just giving this guy
the stink eye over here hey did you
think you saw something well you
certainly did not sorry madam right I
can't get enough of it either wish you
died in snaps oh that damn unicorn again
we'll just take this with me now take
normal normal normal normal normal
normal normal whatever I'll leave that
there for normal normal speakers off
that means it's safe for me to talk
about how we get our meat from what oh
jeez what I was saying was it's safe to
talk about how we get our meat from
nowhere
you get your meat from nowhere yeah
that's perfectly believable that milk
company
okay normal something don't seem right
there but whatever I'll just go to the
back
whoa sushi Douai Evie sushi oh I wanted
break I don't know if I really want it
why would you do that no no please you
gotta be bananas
he's moderately terrifying and I want to
run really quick eat more blood
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay I'm gonna grab that I was in doing
an answer
yes sorry babes I I'm gonna get this for
my lovely daughter and then we're gonna
go hey babes here take it take it
sorry that's not what I meant to do I
meant to shove the unicorn into your
face could you please just that's a
great dancer kid good job just gonna
stretch on over this way
okey-dokey oh god don't tell me I have
to do this please scan item okay Paul
enough enough
scan come on scan scan please I'm gonna
assume it's can do did I get it
oh no it's a pizza I didn't get the pita
yeah you take that over there kitty well
that makes two of us
to the carcass how dare this woman yeah
with your family or you can walk home
alone oh god I love this game so much I
love it so much I love this game I love
this game so much is that soda City
moment was a bit aggravating but okay
perfectly normal
alright yes'm tickets and the next
episode all right so we're gonna hold
off into the next one oh I love this
game so much I can't even believe that
was even a question or whether I should
play this til the end
so anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you oh my in the next video
[Music]